all right
um again I think Adam should chime in on
this because he could feel how hard
we're actually
pushing and in the cou cultivation set
and we took him past failures we do that
sometimes but sometimes we do dial it
back but you have to be careful that
you're dialing it back to
your current state says that you're only
supporting your current state and not
the transformation from your current
State you have to go to past failure
Point okay um at least occasionally some
people say like you know 10 they try to
give it a percentage time 10 10 15 20%
failure rate uh is what you want in your
training um I don't think that the the
main part is that you're not lying to
yourself by manipulating your training
environment to not expose uh where your
limits are to you that's the main point
okay
so
um when we do
the C set and like we're
pushing um sometimes we I you'll see my
Desi where you can't really tell except
for who's grabbing who's doing the
grounding drill and that's cuz they're
at that at that level okay um but when
they first started I I want them to to
Really Drive really drive and I'd let
him drive and I'd have like two or three
people trying to push so they would
know
um where what they're doing and what
they're not doing okay so if Virginia if
I have a bracing angle for example like
A-frame bracing angle you you can use
two hands right I'm stronger than her
she's not she's not going to push that
over okay um but when I put you in Han
me and I don't have that angle and she's
she's
driving I don't want to see that but I
need to see
that I don't want her to just push so I
so I can stand there she she has to be
able to push push push push push push
and I have to be able to stay in
position without needing that bracing
angle okay and so again this is where
Adam could talk because his tire his
tire like he's tiring on the UK he's
like can't do it okay but you need to
have your UK push like that okay um and
then
also when we do the the projection part
so we do the projection part it's not
that she stops pushing she's still
driving so as I go back she's still
pushing just as hard she's pushing just
as hard and I still have to go
forward it's not
that they start pushing she goes back
and now I stop pushing do you see and
now she comes forward and then pushes so
I have
to push she goes back I'm still pushing
she has to come forward against that
still pushing okay um that said when we
do when I I get when they get to a point
where both parties are grounding I
it is not the case that they're not
pushing they're actually more efficient
so if if I'm here and I do this bracing
angle she's going going going she's
pretty good but once I once I used the
ground she not it's not good at all so
that's a higher push even though on
camera it does not look like it okay but
you have to get your training Partners
to just drive drive drive
into you to actually be pushing you over
okay